[Música]
hablar de sexualidad no solo es hablar
de genitalidad tiene tantas aristas que
son importantes para nuestra vida
nuestra sexualidad no comienza cuando
tenemos nuestra primera experiencia
sexual o vital ni termina cuando
cumplimos 60 o 70 años
soy Patricia Espinosa Castellares tengo
una carrera poco convencional soy
peruana soy sexóloga de profesión y la
verdad es que nunca pensé serlo las
cosas se fueron presentando y todo fue
naciendo porque me gusta explorar y
conocer
a lo largo de mi carrera he conocido e
interactuado con distintas poblaciones
he trabajado con adolescentes con padres
con militares con policías con personas
privadas de su libertad con profesores
he atendido a diferentes profesionales y
no profesionales y orientado a mujeres
con vocación pastoral
y también a trabajadoras sexuales
incluso fui parte del jurado para un
casting de actores porno
uno de mis tantos momentos interesantes
puede conducir un programa radial en mi
país Perú un programa de sexualidad sexo
a la medianoche
se metió por 4 años consecutivos de
lunes a viernes
lo más importante para poder trabajar en
tu profesión ha sido no juzgar y tener
mucha pero mucha curiosidad
ustedes tienen curiosidad de saber qué
caso se escucha una sexóloga en Perú
tengo muchos recuerdos que hoy quiero
compartir
quizás algunos piensen que vamos a
contarle sobre poseso método pero no
necesariamente ser así
por ejemplo recuerdo mucho el caso de
una mujer era abogada y había salido
embarazada de su pareja simple dificar
el hombre como muchos quizás en nuestros
países al enterarse del embarazo lavando
no
para ella como para muchas no fue fácil
enfrentar a sus padres a la sociedad
sobre todo creo enfrentar una maternidad
obligada
el caso es que desde que recordaba tu
hija la madre siempre le había dicho que
lo mejor hubiera sido no tenerla
esta tarde cuando llegan al consultorio
primera vez su hija ya adolescente le
había dicho y lo que quería es que ella
se muriera
dos mujeres
enfrentadas en sus propias emociones
dos mujeres viviendo una sexualidad
dañada dos mujeres que nunca aprendieron
a mirarse sin culpa
esto es parte de nuestra sexualidad
pero de una sexualidad sin educación
integral
muchas personas que piensan que hablar
de sexualidad es solo hablar de tener
relaciones sexuales y entiende las
relaciones sexuales como solo la
penetración
en gran parte la responsabilidad es por
nuestra falta de educación e información
y desde ese desconocimiento consumimos
lo que está la mano y repetimos sin
cuestionarnos patrones usualmente
aprendemos de nuestros padres pueden ser
nuestros amigos los primos
adolescencia ahora buscamos respuestas
en Internet y creemos encontrarás muchas
veces en la pornografía
y la pornografía
justamente es todo lo que no es
sexualidad la pornografía tiene que ver
con genitalidad
ustedes entienden
sexualidad
la sexualidad de la forma de ser de
sentir de compartir de entender tiene
que ver con afectos complacer con
responsabilidad con protección con
prevención con autocuidado y bienestar
no solamente es lo físico sino también
lo emocional
la sexualidad tiene que ver con el deseo
con la pasión con nuestras conductas con
nuestras elecciones
es decir hablar de sexualidad va mucho
más allá de lo que nos enseñaron
elegir a quien darle un primer beso
explorar nuestros cuerpos o con quien
explorar los es sexualidad el
enamoramiento el embarazo o la
interrupción del embarazo
tiene que ver con sexualidad y con
educación sexual integral
recuerdo cuando Pedro vamos a llamarlo
así me contó que su primera experiencia
sexual fue a los 14 años en un
prostíbulo me dijo que no fue la mejor
experiencia que por el contrario le dio
mucho miedo y ya está fastidie
quizá por la inexperiencia él decía que
por el trato de la trabajadora sexual
Pedro también recordaba y un poco
ruborizado que espiaba a las amigas de
su hermana pero también a las amigas de
su madre
recuerdo me decía que a mí me daba miedo
ser descubierto
Pedro se casó tres veces la primera a
los 19 años
tu pareja tenía 16 ahora sus hijos de
este primer compromiso tienen 31 y 27
actualmente con su última pareja tiene
una bebé de un año 4 meses
todos ellos no fueron planificados esto
que acabo de compartirles tiene que ver
con nuestra sexualidad
y con la falta de educación sexual Pedro
tomo decisiones para muchos no
necesariamente las correctas la
planificación familiar es poder decidir
cuando y cuántos hijos tener esto es
parte de nuestro ser hecho pero qué
sucede cuando no tenemos esa posibilidad
de elegir o de ejercer nuestros derechos
el abuso sexual y la trata de personas
son un grave problema que nos cueste
radicar en muchos países y eso tiene que
ver con educación sexual integral con
compromisos por parte de nuestros
estados temas también como las diversas
infecciones transmitidas sexualmente
sobre todo
entonces si hablamos de abuso sexual o
de vi ayer estamos hablando de
sexualidad
es un virus que apareció para sacudir al
mundo para confrontar no socialmente
antes perdidas masivas y empujo el
sistema de salud a buscar de manera
desesperada una solución
un virus puede cambiar nuestra vida para
siempre y nosotros ahora no sabemos
lo sabemos perfectamente sabemos que una
pandemia trae cambios drásticos y que
puede modificar nuestra manera de
concebir la sexualidad
nuestra sexualidad
inclusive en estos tiempos que nos ha
tocado vivir en pandemia la pregunta más
recurrente ha sido si existe la
posibilidad de contagiarnos de covid-19
teniendo relaciones con nuestra pareja y
la respuesta de muchos expertos en el
tema es que teniendo un encuentro sexual
coital no existiría riesgo siempre y
cuando en este encuentro no nos dejemos
o nos iremos cerca
lo que yo diría es que si no es tu
pareja y es alguien ocasional tengas
todos los cuidados necesarios
y ahora las sugerencias para continuar
disfrutando de nuestra vida sexual y
evitar el contagio es tener práctica
segura por ejemplo ver juntos una
película erótica o practicar el sexy
claro sabiendo que este contenido podría
compartirse sin nuestro consentimiento
todo el sexiness enviarnos por las redes
sociales oa través de celular mensajes
calientes inclusive fotografías de
alguna parte de nuestro cuerpo
lo importante es cuidarnos cuidar a
quienes amamos y seguir disfrutando de
una vida sexual sólida y firme según
como tú te sientas bien y esto no es
fácil por la forma en como fuimos
educados sexualmente
Latinoamérica está llena de prejuicios y
Perú es un país conservador
aunque más que conservador yo diría
diste una doble moral porque no siempre
practicamos lo que decimos menos en el
tema sexual
no todos o todas hemos tenido acceso a
recibir información sobre temas sexuales
lo que va a perpetuar los mitos y
prejuicios por eso siempre he creído que
lo más importante es la información
clara sencilla y si nuestros propios
prejuicios
durante mucho tiempo he escuchado
diversas historias no sabría decir cuál
es la más increíble o interesante porque
de alguna manera todas lo han sido
recuerdo por ejemplo otro caso un
consultante
entre alguna de las cosas que me comentó
me decía que nunca había estado con una
pareja enfocado en el amor que le
gustaba mucho el sexo que le gustaba
fantasear es me confesaba que había
tenido muchas parejas sexuales pero no
se había sentido como
el había terminado en un colegio militar
desde el tercer al quinto año estudio en
este cole
me daba mucho temor el tamaño de su pene
el temía que no fuera lo suficiente para
sus parejas o quizá que no fuera tener
una buena erección o un buen rendimiento
sexual me decía que hasta ahora siento
como siempre he tratado de mostrarme
como un Superman o como alguien quien no
soy
y esto lo hacía por temor a defraudar a
sus padres
lo que él no decía era que su
orientación no era heterosexual y eran
lo que más lo consumimos
y bueno esta historia puede ser de
cualquiera de nosotros y tiene que ver
con nuestra sexualidad
todas las historias que les he
compartido hoy pudieron tomar un rumbo
distinto y sus protagonistas hubieran
tenido menos prejuicios y más acceso o
mejor acceso a la educación e
información
aunque no parezca la educación sexual o
la falta de ella en países como Perú
marcan la agenda de otros problemas
sociales que afectan la salud la
economía la política porque todo tiene
que ver con sexualidad
como decía cuco
debemos no solo defendernos sino
afirmarnos y a firmar no solo como
identidad sino como fuerza creadora
necesitamos tener acceso a todo tipo de
información y desprendernos de nuestros
prejuicios para poder tomar nuestras
propias decisiones
informados y al mismo tiempo respetar
las decisiones de los demás así no
estemos de acuerdo
siempre tomando en cuenta el
consentimiento sin atentar contra
alguien
la unión no se logra haciendo iguales
sino respetando las diferencias para
poder acoger a todas las personas sin
importar su condición orientación una
sociedad un país el mundo te hace mejor
cuando aceptamos las diferencias
creo firmemente que con una educación
sexual integral
responsable y de calidad
podemos ser agentes de caca
si pueden entenderlo entonces pueden
hacerlo